the jurgen experience another thing in
once upon a time in hollywood that got
controversial was the bruce lee scenes
yeah yeah a lot of people felt like you
you made bruce lee
into an [ __ ] yeah well okay that's
again
i'm a little hesitant to talk about this
because i don't want like this to be the
only thing all right
people pull from from this show but i
figured you were going to bring it up
especially because i heard you guys
go back and forth on it in a little bit
i mean where i'm coming from is
i can understand his daughter having
a problem with it it's her [ __ ]
father all right i get that
but anybody else go suck a dick
you know and the thing about it though
is like you know even if you just look
at
it it's obvious click cliff
tricked him that's how he was able to do
it he tricked him
you know it's like it's it it's it's
explained more in the book but
the thing is like they they do a they do
a three-fall
a two falls out of three contests
so cliff loves [ __ ] like that you know
uh uh and he has a method and his method
is
to give the guy the first fall okay
do your [ __ ] move dude right let me
see your move
all right he gives them no resistance
whatsoever
the guy does the move he knocks him on
his ass
and cliff and there's there's like four
different ways bruce could have come at
him the second time
that cliff wouldn't would have had very
little defense against
but most of the time if if
a guy has a particular move and it looks
like the guy's a lung kid just a big
mouth
who can't really defend himself they do
the second move again
i mean they do the first move again
second time well now cliff knows what it
is
so he prepares for it he pivots he
catches him he throws his ass into the
car
right you know and now the third time
will be the charm and gets broken up but
he just tricked him
and bruce realized he got tricked if if
cliff hadn't been so vicious he could
have even
appreciated it do you know about the
history of uh oh yeah and gene labelle
yeah of course did you
research that before yeah well i've
always known it and everything
and like well the stuntman hated bruce
really on on on
on uh green hornet no it's in the it's
in matthew paulie's book
and before that i've it's always been
known that's why gene labelle was
brought on
to teach bruce respect for american
stuntmen bruce had nothing but
disrespect for stuntman
and he was always hitting them he was
always hitting them with his feet he was
always tagging us called tagging
when you when you hit a stuntman for
real and he was always tagging him with
his feet and he was always tagging him
with his fist and they
and they and they got to be the point
where like no i refused to work with him
really and he had nothing but disrespect
for american stuntmen
huh that's interesting i wonder what
that was about
i wonder what his perspective would have
been if somebody asked him to explain it
uh it's like uh wow they're just not
good enough they're they're [ __ ]
hmm i'm gonna make it look real okay
so he was hitting him to make it look
real yeah yeah
but they don't like that no that's
unprofessional
well that is unprofessional but that's
been done before in a bunch of movies by
people that people say are [ __ ] yeah
and yeah and well
yeah and and um you know and
actually somebody else who had a
reputation pretty similar
to bruce lee's in that regards was like
robert conrad oh yeah during that time
yeah
and you know he did a lot of his own
stunts and he did some really really
gnarly [ __ ] but if you and i've always
been a big fan of robert conrad
but you know in the stunt community he
was known as robert never met a stunt
man he couldn't blame
conrad um the stunt world is a
[ __ ] crazy world because they're the
people that occasionally die
making movies yeah absolutely which is
just nuts and look and the thing about
it is also
cliff is a hand-to-hand combat
killer he you know
you know he fought in world war ii he
fought with the filipino resistant
fighters
you know in the philippines against the
japanese
if cliff fought bruce lee at one of
aaron banks's madison square garden
tournaments cliff wouldn't stand a
chance against bruce lee
at a mountain square garden martial arts
tournament
but as a killer who has killed men
before
in a jungle he'd kill bruce lee
he'd [ __ ] kill him bruce lee's not a
killer
bruce lee's never really let loose on
anybody he's always had to keep it
together
in a martial arts tournament kind of
kind of kind of way
if he's actually facing a guy who could
actually kill him
it's a different story you know it's
it's
it's in the book bruce lee realizes when
cliff takes a hand to hand a military
hand-to-hand combat stance
you know he realized oh [ __ ] this guy's
a killer
this guy's not fighting me he's fighting
his instinct to kill me
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience